If you live in a city , you've probably
seen tens of thousands of passing faces
in your lifetime.
But how many of those faces can you recognize
if you saw them again?
New research suggests you could
probably recall around 5,000 of them.
For the study the researchers divided the
faces people knew into two categories:
personally known faces, like your neighbor,
and public figures like musicians.
Participants were given an hour to recall faces in their
personal lives, which meant that they could either
form a mental image of the face or
believe they would recognize the person
if they saw them.
Researchers provided several categories to help jog the
participants memories: friends, commuters,
classmates, colleagues and more.
Next, participants completed the same recall
task, but with public figures.
Of course it's hard to come up with every face in
your memory, so to account for this,
researchers created a database of over
3,000 famous faces to show participants.
Participants went through two versions
of the database with the same people,
but different photographs.
If the participant correctly identified the person in both sets,
scientists considered the yes response valid.
For every famous face the participant recalled,
They recognized approximately 4.6 faces from the
famous face database.
Using this ratio of recalled faces to recognized faces,
researchers estimated that on average
people know around 5,000 faces,
with the lower end of recognition at around a
1,000 and the higher end a whopping
10,000 faces.
How many faces do you think are stored in your memory?